the main bridge linking canada to the
u.s is open again police enforcing a
court order ended the six-day blockade
by protesters demanding an end to
covered restrictions they made several
arrests and set up barricades to stop it
happening again the protest hits supply
chains on both sides of the border
but outside canada's parliament in
ottawa protesters are refusing to leave
even as the local government eases
covert restrictions
prime minister justin trudeau has had
enough invoking special emergency
measures to confront the protesters
this is not
a peaceful protest
at the borders in different parts of the
country the blockades are harming our
economy and endangering public safety
the 1988 emergencies act allows the
federal government to ensure security
during national emergencies this has
never been used a similar move was last
employed in 1970 the prime minister then
trudeau's father pierre
the scope of these measures
will be
time limited
geographically targeted
as well as reasonable
and proportionate the so-called freedom
convoy protests began because canadian
truckers opposed a vaccine or quarantine
mandate for cross-border drivers
but it soon became a rallying point for
people opposing the trudeau government
and now it's spawned copycat protests
globally
in belgium demonstrators there were
joined by others from france holland and
germany to demand a halt to covert
restrictions by europe's governments
the message is leave us alone we are
peaceful we will leave you alone we are
not accepting any jabs anymore
and in israel a convoy of trucks drove
the main highway from tel aviv to
jerusalem heading for the parliament
building
we all support canada and support the
truckers convey that went up
to ottawa and we do hear the same
critics have accused the so-called
freedom convoys of having little popular
support but authorities are aware of the
disruption even small protests can cause
and like canada are now examining what
actions are available to keep roads
bridges and supply lines open
alan fisher al jazeera washington